ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BAKER OR JUST BRADFORD
CABALLERO QUARTET THREE DALLY
DODD THE RAZA YEAH EGGMAN
PLEASE. GONZALEZ ROVE HERTZBERG
HUESO HURTADO JONES LAYARD
LEYVA WIRE MELENDEZ IN NEWMAN
NIELSEN A SHOW OF BOTH. PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
AMBERG WHAT KASKY WIENER WILK.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WHAT OUR MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE. WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR- BURKE. AFTER WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
REMAIN STANDING AND WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE BY
SENATOR JONES CENTER ABOUT.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT LOVING
GOD OUR FATHER OR MOTHER TODAY
WE THANK YOU FOR THE INDIGENOUS
WOMEN OF THE WORLD- THROUGHOUT
THE AGES OF USE THEIR SACRED
WISDOM AND CLOSE RELATIONSHIP
TO THE EARTH THE NATURE. AND
HEAL THE SAKE FOR THE SAKE OF
ALL IN TIMES OF WARS
DISPLACEMENT AND THE
GENERATIONS OF TRAUMA IMPOSED
ON THEM THEY HAVE CHALLENGED
THE FORCES OF POWER AND
DOMINATION TO BRING ABOUT
POSITIVE CHANGE AND HOPE FOR
THE FUTURE OF THEIR CHILDREN.
TODAY THEY TAKE THEIR PLACE
AMONG THE MANY WOMEN WHO WORK
SILENTLY TO ADVANCE THE
PROGRESS OF OUR CIVILIZATION
PEOPLE LIKE MARIGOLD- ROSS A
CHEROKEE WOMAN WHO BECAME THE
FIRST NATIVE AEROSPACE
ENGINEER. GRACIOUS GOD HELP US
ALL WOMEN AND MEN TO BREAK THE
SILENCE IS THAT HOLD US CAPTIVE
TO FEAR INTIMIDATION PREJUDICE
AND ILLOGICAL THINKING MAY WE
CONTINUE TO SPEAK WORDS OF
COURAGE COMPASSION TRUE. SO
THAT THOSE VOICES STILL UNHEARD
CONVERGENCE STRENGTH OF THEIR
POWER AND DIGNITY FOR THE
BENEFIT. OF OUR WORLD AMEN. YES
I BELIEVE THIS IS TO THE BLACK
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
IT STANDS ONE NATION. MEMBERS
TODAY WE HAVE CENTERS ALL
MONNING AND STERN PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. GOOD MORNING SENATORS
HOPE YOU CAN HEAR US. MOVING
NOW TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WOULD BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES SENATOR SKINNER. YOU
WANT ME TO GO OVER TO THE OTHER.
CAN YOU READY FINISHED PAR YOUR
CERTAIN. SEXUAL YEAH. WILL TAKE
ME JUST A MOMENT MISTER
BRADFORD. I WAS GOING ARTISTS
AND THEN I'LL BE ABLE TO DO IT
WILL JUST. I HAVE IT HERE SO
THAT YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON. OUR CENTER SKINNER WE'RE
GOING TO DEFER FOR A MOMENT
WILL COME BACK TO YOU- FEW
MINUTES LATER. REMOVING ABOUT
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE WE'RE MOVING TO SECOND
READING A FILE MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BELLS FORTY
ONE WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL
SIXTY FOUR WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY NINE
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS AND SENATE BILL
FOR THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU
MOVING NOW TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. CENTER BAITS ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR THE
APPOINTMENTS. YEAH CENTER BATES
OR YOU PREFER OR THE. YOU HAVE
MISSED PRESIDENT I AM APPLYING.
PLEASURE. FILE ITEM NO NINE IS
THE COMP OF SUSAN FRIEDMAN
DIANA HER CAN CHRISTOPHER TO
THE BOARD OF BEHAVIOR FINE. ALL
APPOINTEES WERE PRE IN THIS
RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH THIRD
FUNNYMAN ADAM FIVE VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. FOR ANY FURTHER THE- OR
DEBATE. AS IT RELATES TO A- ANY
DISCUSS OF BATES AS RELATES TO
APPLY SEE NINE MA'AM SECRETARY
PLAY CALL THE ROLL UP. WITH
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS.
BATES I BAKER. FIVE PORGES.
BRADFORD I CABALLERO. I CORTES
HE HI DALLY I DODD HI DURAZO. I
EGGMAN I GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. I HERTZBERG HI HUESO.
FIVE FURTADO I JONES I LAYERED
HI LEYVA I MCGUIRE I WILL. I
MILLION. I KNEW. I NIELSEN. I A
CELLO BOTH HI PAN. I PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH HI RUBIO. I SKINNER.
SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WIENER. I WILK HI.
MANSER PLEASE CALL OUT MEMBERS.
ATKINS REGIS HI THE- HIS SIX
KNOWS THE APARTMENT CONFIRM. WE
NOW TO FILE ITEM TEN. THERE'S
NO OTHER BUSINESS. I'M SORRY
COMMITTEES IN AND OUT OF SOME
SORT. FILE ITEM TEN SENATE
BATES THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN IF THE
CONFIRMATION OF MICHAEL RICH
WINE AS THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
CHIEF RICHWINE BEGAN HIS CAREER
WITH THE CITY OF HANFORD FIRE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN WITH CAL
FIRE SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX
AND HAD BEEN SERVING AS ACTING
STATE FIRE MARSHAL SINCE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN HE WAS APPROVED IN THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
THIRD ON THE UNANIMOUS FIVE
ZERO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR- VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENT. IN NINE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
BATES. I BAKER I FOR JUST. HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI CORTESE I
DALLY. I DON. I RAZA. I EGGMAN.
I GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ HI GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG HI HUESO. HI HER
TADO I JONES. JOE FIVE LAYERED
I LEYVA. FIVE AYE MULLIN. FIVE
MEN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. BY A
SHOW OF BOTH I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER HI I'M BURKE I WHITE
HOUSE SKI. HI WIENER AYE WILK
HI. FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
PERMITS ARE CONFIRMED WE'RE
GONNA MOVE BACK OUT TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS CENTER SKINNER
YOU PREPARED. SAID THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- MMHM. I THANK MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS BY MOVED
ADOPTION OF AUTHORS MAY FOR
BUDGET. THE WILL CROSS THE DESK
OR FRIDAY CHAU AND SUNDAY MARCH
TWELFTH THIRTEENTH AND
FOURTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THESE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
ADOPTED PUBLISHED IN THE
MEASURES RETURNED TO THE
COMMITTEE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON. FIRST
ALLIED FOR INQUIRY- OF THE
CHAIR BY COMMITTEE. THE
QUESTION. WHICH BUT THE
QUESTION OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE PERSON KILLED CENTERS
SENATORS GENERAL YOU ENTERTAIN
OR FROM CENTER YES I WILL
SENATOR SKINNER OR ANY OF THE-
INCORPORATED OVER THE WE D.
WITH U. OF THE. TO- NO THEY
WILL NOT THEY WILL NOT. I WILL
THEN ASK FOR A NO VOTE. THIS IS
GOING TO BE RUSHED THROUGH.
WHEELS GET VERY LITTLE TIME TO
REVIEW AND THE DELIBERATE ON
MONDAY WILL BE LEARNING RIGHT
STRAIGHT TO THE FLOOR AFTER
COMMITTEE ON MONDAY. AND
THERE'S A VERY EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT ISSUE NOT DEALT WITH
IN THE BUDGET THE GOVERNOR'S
NOR THIS ONE. S. B. T. V. SO I
WOULD ASK FOR A NOBLE. THANK
YOU CENTER ANY JUST OR ON THIS
ITEM. IN TWO NINETY. I'M SO
PLEASED THE ROLL CENTERS
CONGESTION FOR WROTE INTERNAL
OUT TO FOR NOBLE. ALLEN I URGE.
AYE ATKINS. BATES NO BACKER. I
FORGES NO BRADFORD I CABALLERO
HI CORTESE I DOLLY. NO DOUBT. I
TORONTO I EGGMAN HI GLAZER. I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG.
FIVE HI HER TADO I JONES NO
LEHRER I LEYVA I MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ NO MAN. I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. NO A BOTH NO HAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH. HI RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER HI NUMBER NINE HI
WHAT KIND OF SKI I WIENER. I
WILL. NO I STRONGLY SO NO NINE
THE MOST PASSES. MEMBERS OF
MOVING NOW TO. COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. CINNABAR. YEAH.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT IN THE
AND GOOD MORNING THE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE WILL BE
CONVENING AT. NINE FORTY FIVE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
MEMBERS GOVERNOR'S AND FINANCE
TO CONVENE AT NINE FORTY FIVE
AM ROOM FORTY TWO OLD THREE.
CENTER RUBIO. THANK MEMBERS THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON IN WILL
CONVENE HERE WE ADJOURN THIS
MEETING THING YOU. INSURANCE
CAN WILL MEET ON SENATE
CHAMBERS UPON A GERMAN OF
SESSION THIS MORNING. ANY
FURTHER ANNOUNCEMENTS SURE
SCENERY NINE IF THERE'S NO
FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER
HERTZBERG DRESSES CLERK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WE MADE
AND WE WILL COULD RECONVENE
HERE ON MONDAY AT TWO PM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MEMBERS THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY OR WHICH TIME
THEIR GERMAN